so there and there we got another guy
right here is this antifa again this
ain't it
oh no park city like bro
they were so loud out there oh bro they
were
you know me stevie and jay were saw the
daryl oh there's a deer everyone's damn
that's cool
and then wait wait oh [ __ ] it's a dare
it's all [ __ ] it's a damn god damn
it used to be deer valley sounds valley
resort over there
now what's interesting is i we have to
leave these three look at this because
they they weren't used to biking so we
win
left them behind me going my own pace
and i was worried about chapelle you're
[ __ ] [ __ ] this side parking
side
chappelle going that sauce dude the
white people were so encouraging to us
how about justin ate [ __ ] blew his nikes
out
yeah we went up three times came down
we're eating
finally they came down once right and i
look at justin has a huge bandage all
over
oh he was bleeding he ate it bad well
the whole idea is preposterous of
getting
fat people on the bikes like it's a just
outlandish that's the business no i
understand the business model business
and i think it's positive look
i like what you guys are doing you guys
are the clayton biggs these are the
trails
now you guys you were just saying how
you like that i don't know you're
against it i
just think long term the the physical
right when it comes to physical
brendan look what's going on with you
guys you you're strong enough but you're
getting guys out there with bad
pressure bad sugar you're right i was
worried about them hey i didn't fall
once you didn't fall
once i did i didn't did malik yeah malik
fell
justin fell i didn't i can do backflips
i'm not gonna fall off a mountain well
well you're right
well okay but so but i'm just saying
that you guys
can do better i think i'm sorry guys
huh the big guys it's just how when does
somebody has a stroke
you know yeah you're right it was hot
out there too
was it i was worried about him and y'all
better bury him if they do
yep right there on the right there on
the mountain right there on the trail
oh thick boy headstones what about that
an extra thick headstone
yeah dude that thing's thick that
thing's a foot
deep man eight inch wide headstone a
foot deep bro it's not a bad idea
dude that ski lift was scary though was
it that was our first time going that
was all of our first time going on there
that thing went up pretty high
and plus we didn't know there's a safety
bar that locks you in so we were just
sitting there like
without the safety bar yeah we were
holding on to the pole wow we was just
holding on
dude come on was in the middle he was
just holding on to me and malik
because we didn't know nobody told you
about the scene well there's people
coming the other way and they go
pull down the bar and we were like oh
okay and then we found them we're the
only
black guys on the mountain yeah we're
only two black guys up there yeah look
look at we don't have the bars we're
just holding it look how scary they are
nothing's scarier than seeing three
black dudes
in mass not behind bars okay
so obviously those people are saying hey
more more bars put the bars down man
yeah yeah dude yeah
but yeah man i can also understand why
you guys don't want to do it man
stevie was a little nervous about the
bars too man with this
earlier prison sentence stevie weavey
was to he was there tv blue
who is that stevie blue you never met
stevie blue eyes i'm not
comic wait is he married to eliza
schlesinger no
no no no no no that is not him
no oh that's great though you guys had a
good crew man it sounded like you guys
had a good time was it yeah it was fun
it was a lot of fun